In this session today,
we're going to talk about it,
aggravating circumstances.
Uh,
and we looked at the cases in 1976 when the supreme court upheld the death
penalty.
And as we saw in every state,
Florida,
Georgia,
Texas,
the ones that were upheld,
uh,
it was the death penalty was upheld not only for murder,
but with one other thing,
murder and the commission of an arm robbery,
murder that was particularly a heinous,
atrocious and cruel,
uh,
those kinds of additional factors.
A murder of a police officer.
Uh,
we saw that some states put those at the penalty phase of the trial.
And we saw that other states,
uh,
put those,
at,
at the,
at the guilt phase,
such as in Texas,
where one of the,
in order to be convicted of capital murder,
it has to be murder of a police officer,
a murder in the commission of another felony where there were a lot of issues
that remained about whether these aggravating circumstances actually do what the
court said they're supposed to do.
And that is to guide the discretion of the jury.
The idea of the aggravating circumstances and mitigating circumstances is that
the jury,
unlike in the preferred days before Furman versus Georgia,
when a jury just decided without any guidance whether to impose death or not,
now the discretion of the jury was going to be clearly guided,
like clear and objective standards that we'll see.
And that's to prevent the arbitrariness.
We'll see that,
uh,
the court retreats from that quite a bit as we look at these cases.
Uh,
today in this session,
uh,
Zant versus Stevens is the first case I'd like to take a look at.
This is a case that sort of illustrates how the Georgia death penalty statute
work.
There were three aggravating circumstances alleged by the prosecutor murder with
a prior capital felony or a person with a prior history of a serious sexual,
uh,
assaults.
Uh,
the [inaudible].
This is the broad,
uh,
vile,
horrible inhuman.
The murderer was outrageously wantingly,
vile,
horrible,
and inhuman.
Uh,
and third mercy murder by a person who escaped from lawful custody.
Zan argued that,
uh,
Fermin was violated,
because the jury had complete unbridled discretion once it found one of these
aggravating circumstances.
But it got even a little more complicated than that because when the case went
to the Georgia Supreme Court,
it struck,
well,
first of all,
the jury didn't find the middle circumstance,
the B seven,
the outrageously wantonly vial,
Harbin and human.
It only found two when the case went to the Supreme Court of Georgia.
It found that one of those,
uh,
was unconstitutionally vague.
So it struck that down.
But it's still upheld Stephen's death sentence based on the one remaining
aggravating circumstance that had been submitted to the jury.
Uh,
Steven's challenges that he says,
first of all,
as I said before,
the jury has given complete discretion just like in Furman versus Georgia,
it can decide
to give death or life.
Uh,
and,
and secondly,
he was worried that the jury may have given weight to that aggravating
circumstance that was later declared unconstitutional because the jury might
think logically if they're too,
that must be worse than having one.
And that might've contributed to his death since,
uh,
well the supreme court rejected that and an opinion by justice Stevens,
for,
uh,
seven justices.
The court asked Georgia to explain how the system worked.
And the Georgia Supreme Court wrote back or wrote an opinion that said,
basically,
we have a pyramid in which all the murders at the bottom of the pyramid.
Uh,
then there's some that are,
uh,
what,
what Georgia calls malice murderer,
some that are in a second higher level.
And once a murderer's in that level,
if there is one or more aggravating circumstances,
it goes to the very top of the pyramid.
And there the jury has complete and absolute discretion to decide whether or not
to impose the death poem.
A lot of people thought when they said that,
that it did sound an awful lot like Fermin.
And that may be,
uh,
the Georgia death pony was in jeopardy.
Once again,
uh,
but the justices,
seven justices,
uh,
and in this opinion by justice Stevens,
embrace that and basically said,
uh,
that this,
scheme,
this pyramid,
uh,
system that Georgia had as long as no special weight is given to any one
aggravating factor.
Uh,
and there's,
there's no weighing in Georgia we talked about before,
there's some states where they weigh aggravating and mitigating circumstances.
And Georgia is once an aggravating circumstances found,
the jury has complete discretion to impose whatever sentence it wants to.
Um,
and so what the court finds is that there is a narrowing that is the aggravating
circumstances narrowed the group of people who were eligible for the death
public.
And now we learned that's all the eighth amendment requires just simply
narrowing a Justice Marshall descents,
uh,
he points out that this is no different than Furman versus Georgia.
Once the jury has reached that top level of the pyramid,
it has complete and unbridled discretion.
And he said the idea that we adopted in our 19,
uh,
76 cases,
was that the jury's discretion would be guided by clear and objective standards.
Um,
the court next takes us up in law and fell versus Phelps,
which is a case in which the same factor,
the guilt phase,
the person was eligible for death.
If they killed or inflicted inflicted great bodily harm to more than one person,
then you go to the penalty phase.
Uh,
and that same factor is an aggravating factor at the penalty phase.
law and fellows arguing this can't be right.
It can't be that you can duplicate a,
what's part of the crime at the guilt phase and make it an aggravating
circumstance at the penalty phase because it's sort of automatic aggravating
circumstance.
Again,
the court says,
no problem with this as long as it narrows the class.
Uh,
Louisiana,
which is where this case came from,
could narrow the class at the guilt phase by making this capital murder or it
could do it at the penalty phase.
Um,
as long as the narrowing function was served,
uh,
the jury,
was,
was within the eighth amendment requirements,
uh,
Justice Marshall,
again to sense for basically the same reason,
uh,
that he had before.
The other issue,
uh,
that,
that is,
uh,
we think about with these a aggravating circumstances is do they really narrow
the class?
Do they,
the,
the idea is that the death pony is reserved for the worst of the worst,
only for the most incorrigible offenders who commit the most heinous crimes.
Uh,
but yet almost every state has some kind of broad catchall aggravating factor,
uh,
in,
Georgia,
Virginia,
uh,
whether the murder is outrageously wantonly,
vile,
horrible,
and inhuman,
uh,
in that it involved torture a depravity of mind or an aggravated battery that
actually gives you some individuals specific factors,
torture,
an aggravated battery.
Uh,
but a lot of the others like Florida and Oklahoma,
heinous,
atrocious and cruel.
Well,
every murder is heinous,
atrocious and cruel.
So does that really limit who gets the death pony and who does not?
Uh,
Arizona,
very similar,
especially heinous,
cruel or deprived as opposed to cruel.
Uh,
and then Idaho has a circumstance which the court will look at utter disregard
for human life to these really narrow the class of people that can be sentenced
to death.
The defendants who can get the death point well,
the court first seems to say yes,
uh,
and ultimately,
seems to,
uh,
back off from that,
Robert Godfrey's case,
uh,
was a man who killed a terrible crime,
killed both his wife and his mother-in-law by just coming in and shooting him
with a shotgun.
Only one aggravating circumstance was alleged by the prosecutor in that case.
And it was the outrageously wantonly vile,
horrible end and human circumstance.
Uh,
there was no torture,
so there was no aggravated battery.
That was,
I said the two things where at least gives the jury,
you know,
particular crimes that are part of that aggravating circumstance.
Uh,
and so the jury is just given the words of the statute.
Nothing more.
Uh,
Supreme Court reverses a justice.
Stewart writes the plurality opinion.
He's joined by Justice Blackmun Powell and Stevens.
Uh,
and then of course,
the Brennan and Marshall Join based on their view that the death penalty is
always unconstitutional.
Uh,
but justice towards says a person of ordinary sensibilities is going to consider
any murder to be outrageous.
Leap,
vile,
harban human.
He credits the Georgia Supreme Court with narrowing it in other cases,
uh,
that there has to be torture or there has to be aggravated battery or that it is
defined depravity of mind in a way,
uh,
that,
means that,
uh,
it's the,
mental state needed to commit either the torture or the aggravated battery,
which we don't have here.
And Robert Godfrey's case,
um,
the Georgia Supreme Court didn't do that in this case though,
when the case was on appeal,
uh,
the Georgia Supreme Court just simply affirmed it.
And the court says there's no principled way to distinguish this case in which
the death penalty was imposed from the many cases.
It was not.
This is justice white.
That's,
uh,
quoting from justice white's concurring opinion in Furman versus Georgia.
Uh,
Justice Marshall joined by Justice Brennan a concur.
But once again,
Justice Marshall makes the point that the jury must be instructed that the jury
has to.
Uh,
he also disagrees that the Ma with the majority saying that,
uh,
the Georgia Supreme Court has limited this to a,
select a group of cases.
He said it's applied to just about every case and then reminds the court of what
it had said and mcgautha versus California,
that it really is not possible to figure out what factors call for the death
Poli and do not,
um,
uh,
chief justice burger to sense as if ever there is a,
a horrible crime are hideous crime.
Even Godfrey himself,
uh,
said.
So.
Also what we see in the descending opinions here,
first from Burger,
the courts are not to second guess the jury's or the state courts.
Uh,
justice white joined by Justice Rehnquist.
the Georgia Supreme Court has responsibly reviewed these cases and this is an
unwarranted invasion in invasion into state law.
Once again,
this tension between what do we leave to the states and what does the Supreme
Court and the federal courts do,
uh,
in terms of trying to a cabin,
the death penalty.
Uh,
the next case is Maynard versus Cartwright.
Here we have a Wayne state.
Now,
unlike Georgia,
we have a state in which the jury is total way the aggravating circumstances
against the mitigating circumstances.
And here the jury found too aggravating factors.
Great risk of death to more than one person and heinous,
atrocious and cruel.
And they found that those two aggravating factors outweighed the mitigating
factors.
Very interesting.
Justice white who had filed a descent and Godfrey is now writing for seven
members of the court,
uh,
with a concurrence.
It says basically unanimous opinion.
Justice Brennan and Marshall Concur,
he says,
Godfrey controls this case got reversed.
This Georgia,
uh,
there's no narrowing of this term,
heinous,
atrocious and cruel.
Uh,
so they don't adequately informed the jury of what it's supposed to find.
the Dustin's is not saved like it was in Zahn versus Stevens by the other
aggravating factor because here the jury weights in Georgia,
as long as there was one valid aggravating factor,
the jury could consider it a death.
But in,
uh,
Oklahoma,
the jury ways and if one of those factors is invalid,
then that means either you have to go back and,
and the state has to go back and try the case again.
Or maybe in some states that the state supreme court can,
can reweigh.
Uh,
so we get into this,
uh,
sort of discussion of the weighing and non wing states,
at this point.
And we'll come back to that in just a minute.
In Brown versus Sanders,
uh,
in,
in two cases,
out of Arizona,
uh,
Walton versus Arizona and,
Louis versus Jeffrey's,
uh,
the court looks at Arizona's especially a heinous,
cruel,
or depraved,
a aggravating factor.
Again,
the challenge that it's so broad,
it doesn't really narrow the class of people eligible for the death penalty.
The court looks to how the Arizona Supreme Court has construed this or has
applied this in cases it finds that it has said,
especially cruel applies to cases where the defendant suffered mental anguish
and especially deprived applies where the defendant relishes or had a sense of
pleasure,
uh,
from,
the,
uh,
murder,
indicating the basement or perversion on the part of the person.
Uh,
based upon these,
uh,
narrowing constructions.
Uh,
the court upholds,
uh,
the,
that statute.
And then we come to a Ravi versus Creech,
which is the I,
uh,
Idaho Supreme Court talking about its utter disregard,
a aggravating factor,
utter disregard for human life.
Why wouldn't anybody who commits a murder show utter disregard for human life?
Uh,
the Idaho Supreme Court says this is the highest,
the utmost,
the most callous disregard for human life.
The cold blooded pitiless slayer,
uh,
who kills without,
feeling or sympathy.
Um,
uh,
again,
the question becomes,
in these cases,
are we just on adjectives one after another or are we really distinguishing some
groups of murders as being more aggravated than some others?
Uh,
court says,
not all Idaho,
uh,
murders.
I like this.
They're not all cold blooded.
They're not all,
uh,
without feeling or sympathy.
Uh,
and the Supreme Court of the United States,
a majority of the court at least says this narrows the class of people a
sufficiently,
uh,
that,
it,
it passes constitutional muster.
Notice here,
it's not that the jury had these definitions in these cases.
Well,
in Arizona was the judge sentencing state at the time.
Uh,
but in,
in,
in Idaho,
it's that the state supreme court can provide a construction,
can narrow it on appeal from the trial court's decision.
Uh,
something,
uh,
that,
is somewhat controversial.
Uh,
finally we come to a brown,
uh,
versus Sanders,
which is a case which in some way it takes away a lot of what we've been talking
about.
Uh,
in California,
jury must first find eligibility factors at the guilt phase.
As we know,
there are two phases to any death pony case.
First,
the question of can the death only be imposed or not?
And then secondly,
uh,
what's sentenced life imprisonment without the possibility of release or the
death pony.
Uh,
in this case,
the jury found four factors at the guilt phase robbery,
a burglary,
a which was later declared invalid by the California Supreme Court witness
elimination.
Uh,
and finally the heinous,
atrocious and cruel circumstance just like the one that Florida and Oklahoma
hat,
uh,
that also is declared invalid,
by the California Supreme Court in its review,
uh,
after the jury comes back with a finding of guilty,
it's told to weigh these factors and the circumstances of the crime,
the background of the defendant and determine penalty.
Uh,
and so after the California Supreme Court finds the burglary in the heinous,
atrocious and cruel to be invalid,
the argument is,
uh,
but because these are invalid,
the death pony can no longer stand.
Uh,
and the supreme court has been treating these differently.
the weighing states,
uh,
states like Oklahoma,
where you weigh aggravating and mitigating circumstances.
The court has said that if one is invalid,
if one aggravating factor is invalid,
that skews the process and therefore you have to either go back and do it again.
Or as I said earlier,
the State Supreme Court has to do it.
Uh,
but in the non weighing states like Georgia,
uh,
the death pony is only set aside a,
if the jury could draw an adverse inference,
a from some constitutionally protected activity that somehow labeled an
aggravating factor or a considerations of the aggravating factor allowed the
jury to consider evidence that otherwise wouldn't have been before.
So Justice Scalia takes these and decides,
now we're going to eliminate the distinction between the weighing states and the
non wink states and we're going to look at what evidence was admitted so that
even if an aggravating factor is invalid,
the court can still uphold the death sentence.
And so the question is,
was the evidence,
uh,
properly admitted?
In other words,
the evidence may have come in for any number of reasons and then the jury may
have been told about these in California what are called special circumstances
and what in most of the countries called aggravating circumstance,
uh,
if the invalid aggravating factor allowed evidence that wouldn't have otherwise
come before the jury,
uh,
or,
then that's a due process violation.
Uh,
so if there's an invalid aggravating circumstance that lets some evidence that
wouldn't otherwise be before the jury come in,
that would require the case to be set aside.
Um,
also,
um,
if the factor added in an improper element to the balancing stage,
uh,
then,
the,
that would be a improper,
but unless one of those things happens,
uh,
the,
the court can just simply affirm,
even though there's an invalid aggravating circumstances,
other justices would take a different approach.
Stevens and Souter say this is not just about eligibility,
but it's about how you impose the death pony.
Uh,
if you,
the non weighing states a finding of four,
four aggravating factors ought to be,
uh,
have greater legal significance than a finding of three.
Uh,
in the weighing states,
uh,
the,
ag weighted,
the aggravating factors determined sin.
So if one of them is invalid,
then that would be presumptively harmful.
This is,
this is not the majority opinion.
This is just what,
uh,
the,
these two justices think.
Uh,
and then justice,
uh,
Bryer and Ginsburg,
would not make a distinction between the wing and non wing states.
They would simply say,
if there is an invalid aggravating factor,
uh,
then you just look to see if it was harmless or not.
Uh,
and that would be,
uh,
how did it affect,
the,
either the wing or the decision making process of the jury?
Uh,
they say this is about,
uh,
the importance that the jury attaches to admissible evidence at the end of the
day.
Uh,
we see this about a aggravating circumstances.
the court backs off of its earlier language about clearly guiding the discretion
of the jury and talks about it must genuinely narrow the class of people who can
get the death Poli.
Uh,
the State Supreme Court can narrow it by the way that it could construes the
aggravating factor when it's on appeal.
Now this is despite the language and Maynard versus Cartwright,
that seemed to say,
uh,
that the jury's had to be advised with regard to the definition of these heinous
crochets and cruel or other catch all aggravating circumstances.
Um,
but,
um,
the federal court is not going to be able to do much if the state supreme court
has limited it.
But finally,
uh,
we see there's going to be little chance of reversal,
regardless of that.
Uh,
because of the Supreme Court's decision,
Brown vs Sanders as a completely different kind of aggravating factor,
which we'll take up in the next segment.
Uh,
future dangerousness,
uh,
which is used in Texas and some other states.